>> THEY TRIED TO SCARE ME.
BUT IT GIVES ME POWER AND AWAY.
I LOVE HILLARY, I LOVE EVERYONE,
BUT THE CAMPAIGN DIDN'T MAKE ME
FEEL LIKE A GUY THAT COULD PLAY
CATCH WITH HIS SON.
THERE WAS SOMETHING ABOUT ONE UP
AT THIS HAT ON AND IT MADE ME
FEEL LIKE SUPERMAN.
YOU MADE A SUPERMAN.
THAT'S MY FAVORITE SUPERHERO.
>> THAT WAS QUITE SOMETHING.
>> I LOVE THIS GUY RIGHT HERE.
I LOVE THIS GUY RIGHT HERE.
>> THAT WAS QUITE SOMETHING, THE
WORDS OF PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THE
OVAL OFFICE TODAY, CONNIE WEST
EXPRESSING HIS SUPPORT AMONG
OTHER THINGS.
THAT IS WHERE WE WILL START WITH
OUR PANEL.
JOSH CRUSH HOUR, POLITICAL
EDITOR FOR THE NATIONAL JOURNAL,
AMY WALTER, NASH MONITORED HER
FOR THE COOK POLITICAL REPORT
AND MOLLIE HEMINGWAY, SENIOR
EDITOR AT THE FEDERALIST.
SO WHAT DOES THAT DO?
IT WAS A SURREAL MOMENT ON TV,
WE HADN'T SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THAT IN THE OVAL OFFICE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IT DOES FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP, OR THE ELECTION
IN ANY WAY?
>> IT CERTAINLY WAS A SURREAL
MOMENT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP LOVES CELEBRITY.
HE LOVED THE BEACH BOYS AND HAD
ANOTHER CELEBRITY IN THE
WHITE HOUSE TODAY BUT IT
REMINDED ME THAT IT COULD BE A
LOST OPPORTUNITY FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IF YOU FOCUSED ON THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM WHICH WAS WHY
CONNIE WEST WAS AT THE
WHITE HOUSE AND THE FIRST PLACE,
THAT COULD HAVE BEEN AN
OPPORTUNITY EARLY ON IN HIS
PRESIDENCY TO EXPAND HIS
COALITION AND WENT OVER SOME
AFRICAN-AMERICANS TO THE TRUMP
SIDE.
IT WAS AN AMAZING MOMENT WHERE
WE HAD ONE OF THE MOST FAMOUS
AFRICAN-AMERICAN CELEBRITIES
HUGGING PRESIDENT TRUMP, BUT IT
FEELS LIKE IT'S LATE IN THE GAME
FOR THAT AND IT DOESN'T FEEL
LIKE THIS CAME AT THE RIGHT TIME
FOR THIS PRESIDENT.
THERE ARE CERTAINLY SOME
OPPORTUNITIES AS WE GET CLOSER
TO THE MIDTERMS WERE TRYING TO
BUILD SOME NEW SUPPORTERS BUT I
DON'T THINK HE WILL MOVE A WHOLE
LOT POLITICALLY.
>> WHAT WAS INTERESTING, WHAT HE
JUST SAID THERE WAS SOMETHING
ABOUT PUTTING ON THAT GIVES HIM
POWER.
I THINK THERE'S SOMETHING IN OUR
CULTURE WHERE THERE'S A LOT OF
CRITICISM OF BEING A
CONSERVATIVE, A TON OF CRITICISM
FOR BEING A TRUMP SUPPORTER BUT
IF YOU CAN WITHSTAND THAT THERE
IS SOMETHING EMPOWERING ABOUT
IT.
KANYE IS INTERESTING AND HE IS
ALWAYS INTERESTING AND SAYS
THINGS IN A WEIRD WAY, BUT I
THINK THE REASON YOU ARE SEEING
SO MUCH NEGATIVE REACTION IS
BECAUSE OF THE THINGS THAT HE IS
RAISING.
YOU HAVE A VERY POPULAR
CELEBRITY ALIGNING HIMSELF WITH
THE PRESIDENT AND THERE'S
SOMETHING VERY ALARMING ABOUT
THAT.
YOU SEE TONS OF HISPANIC
SUPPORTING TED CRUZ, TONS OF
HISPANICS SUPPORTING DEAN
KELLER.
THERE IS SOMETHING THAT PEOPLE
FEEL VERY NERVOUS ABOUT WHEN
PEOPLE DO NOT PLAY THE PARTS
THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO.
>> TO THAT POINT, SOME OTHER
COMMENTATORS WEIGHING IN ON WHAT
WAS GOING TO HAPPEN TODAY WITH
KANYE WEST.
>> KANYE WEST IS WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN DON'T READ IT.
>> BUT NOW ALL OF A SUDDEN
BECAUSE HE PUT ON A HAT AND --
HE'S ALL OF A SUDDEN NOW THE
MODEL SPOKESPERSON OR TOKEN OF
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION?
>> YOU KNOW WHAT I LOVE THAT
LIBERALS TRY TO DO, LIBERALS TRY
TO CONTROL THE BLACK PERSON TO
THE CONCEPT OF RACISM BECAUSE
THEY KNOW WE ARE VERY PROUD OF,
EMOTIONAL PEOPLE.
SO WHEN I SAY I LIKE TRUMP TO
SOMEONE THAT'S A LIBERAL, THEY
SAY, HE'S RACIST.
YOU THINK RACISM CAN CONTROL ME?
THAT DOESN'T STOP ME.
>> Bret: IT'S SUCH AN
EXPLOSIVE THING TO TALK ABOUT.
BUT HOW DOES THIS PLAY?
>> I JUST THINK WE ARE BACK
WHERE WE HAVE ALWAYS BEEN, AND
THE DISCUSSION OF TWO AMERICAS
AND A POLARIZED AMERICA, AND I
DIDN'T SPEND A LOT OF TIME
TALKING ABOUT THE ISSUES THAT WE
THOUGHT WERE GOING TO GET RAISE
RAISED, AND KIM KARDASHIAN AND
HIS WIFE OF COURSE CAME IN AND
ACTUALLY TALKED ABOUT ISSUES
RELATED TO CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM.
INSTEAD, THIS BECOMES ABOUT WHO
HIS TEAM ARE YOU ON.
THE ENTIRE TRUMP PRESIDENCY HAS
BEEN BASICALLY ABOUT PICKING HER
ASIDE AND PICKING OUR TEAM, AND
FOR KANYE TO PUT THE RED HAT ON,
HE IS LITERALLY SAYING I'M GOING
AGAINST MY TEAM AND THERE IS A
BACKLASH TO THAT, IN THE SAME
WAY THAT REPUBLICANS WHO HAVE
SAID -- OR WHO WERE NORMALLY
READY TO GO INTO THE BLUE TEAM,
THEY GET THE CRITICISM FOR DOING
THAT.
THERE IS NOTHING LEFT, THERE
IS -- THE ELECTION WILL JUST
FURTHER GET US INTO THESE DEEP,
DEEP, POLAR -- >> AND WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT THAT FOR A WHILE.
>> EARLIER THIS MORNING,
DONALD TRUMP CALLED INTO FOX AND
FRIENDS AND HAD A LENGTHY
CONVERSATION.
>> SHE WAS REFERENCING CONNIE'S
APPEARANCE.
>> KIM CAME TO THE OVAL OFFICE
AND SHE WAS ACTUALLY VERY
EFFECTIVE AT GETTING THAT
SENTENCE COMMUTED.
BUT THERE ARE CONVERSATIONS THAT
PEOPLE ARE HAVING NOW AND IT'S
GOOD TO SEE THEM ON THE RIGHT
BECAUSE CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM
HAS BEEN SOMETHING THAT
PREVIOUSLY JUST PEOPLE ON THE
LEFT WERE TALKING ABOUT.
YOU SEE A LOT OF GOOD TO
ELEMENTS WITH QUESTIONS ABOUT
MANDATORY MINIMUMS AND HOW WE
ADJUDICATE VARIOUS CASES.
AND IT IS HAPPENING BECAUSE OF
THIS.
>> THE BIGGEST IMPEDIMENT TO
THIS IS SITTING IN HIS CABINET
AND THAT'S JEFF SESSIONS.
REPUBLICANS WANT TO PASS THIS
AND HAVE ENOUGH VOTES IN SENATE
TO PASS THIS.
BUT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IS THE
REAL REASON WHY A LOT OF THE
STUFF ISN'T GETTING DONE.
>> Bret: LET ME TURN TO THE
BIG INTERNATIONAL STORY,
DISMISSING SAUDI JOURNALISTS.
LET'S SEE HOW THE U.S. IS
DEALING WITH IT.
>> WE ARE LOOKING AT IT VERY
STRONGLY AND WE WILL HAVE A
REPORT OUT SOON.
WE ARE WORKING WITH TURKEY AND
SAUDI ARABIA.
WHAT HAPPENED WAS A TERRIBLE
THING, ASSUMING THAT HAPPENED.
MAYBE WE WILL BE PLEASANTLY
SURPRISED BUT SOMEHOW I DOUBT
IT.
>> I TALKED TO SENATOR CORKER
AND CARDIN AND THERE WILL BE A
BIPARTISAN TSUNAMI BILL AGAINST
SAUDI ARABIA HERE, IF THEY DID
IN FACT DO THIS.
>> IT'S VERY UNLIKELY THAT HE
LEFT ALIVE AND IT'S TIME FOR THE
UNITED STATES TO LAY DOWN SOME
CONSEQUENCES FOR THE SAUDIS.
>> Bret: THIS IS THE
DISAPPEARANCE OF JAMAAL
KHASHOGGI AND
"THE WASHINGTON POST" AND
INTELLIGENCE SOURCES ARE SAYING
THAT HE ORDERED THE ACTION.
THE RELATIONSHIP WITH WHAT HAS
BEEN AN IMPROVING RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE KINGDOM.
>> THAT'S NOT WHAT THE
WHITE HOUSE SEEMS TO WANT AND
I'VE BEEN STRUCK BY THE
PRESIDENT'S PASSIVITY AND NOT
REALLY CALLING OUT SAUDI ARABIA.
HE SAYS HE WANTS TO WAIT UNTIL
MORE FACTS BECOME AVAILABLE BUT,
LIKE A LOT OF FOREIGN POLICY
ISSUES YOU SEE THE PRESIDENT
EATING FROM BEHIND TO COME AT
THE REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS.
HE SAW LINDSEY GRAHAM AND MARCO
RUBIO, SOME OF THE HOCKS ON THE
SENATE SIDE THAT WANT ACTION.
THEY MIGHT WANT SANCTIONS, BUT
THE WHITE HOUSE DOESN'T WANT TO
DO THAT.
JARED KUSHNER HAS HAD A CLOSE
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE SAUDI
LEADERSHIP AND I THINK THEY HAVE
A LOT AT STAKE AND THEY DON'T
WANT TO JEOPARDIZE THAT.
>> I THINK THE MESSAGE TODAY
WAS, LET'S SEE WHERE THIS TAKES
US, WHERE WE KNOW TO BE FACTS.
OBVIOUSLY THERE IS INTELLIGENCE
THAT WE ARE NOT SEEN.
>> THAT'S WHAT I WAS GOING TO
SAY, HOW ARE WE GOING TO KNOW
ACTUALLY, WILL HE FEEL LIKE IT
IS A VERY DEFINITIVE CASE THAT
CAN BE TOLD?
WE MAY GET MORE INTELLIGENT, BUT
IF SO THE ACTION WOULD BE AS
JOSH POINTED OUT THAT THING THAT
THE PRESIDENT IS VERY HESITANT
TO DO.
WHICH IS STOP ARMS SALES TO
SAUDI ARABIA.
YOU COULD HAVE A REALLY
TREMENDOUS IMPACT ON THE SAUDI
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WHAT THEY ARE
DOING RIGHT NOW, THEIR PLACE IN
THE WORLD MILITARILY IF THE U.S.
DID PUT SANCTIONS ON SOON.
>> I THINK PEOPLE ARE VERY MUCH
JUMPING THE GUN.
BOTH TURKEY AND SAUDI ARABIA ARE
ALLIES AND THEY HAVE THE HUMAN
RIGHTS PROBLEMS.
TURKEY'S PRESIDENT HAS
IMPRISONED SOMETHING NORTH OF
160 JOURNALISTS -- THE IDEA THAT
YOU WOULD JUST TAKE THEM AT
THEIR WORD, THAT THEY KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT IS GOING ON SEEMS
REALLY PREMATURE.
WHEN YOU ARE MAKING DECISIONS
ABOUT HOW TO DEAL WITH ALLIES,
YOU SHOULD ALWAYS BE FOCUSED ON
YOUR NATIONAL INTEREST.
KIDNAPPING OR KILLING A
JOURNALIST IS A HORRIBLE THING.
IT HAPPENS A LOT, IT'S NOT WORSE
IF IT HAPPENS TO A JOURNALIST
AND SOMEONE ELSE BUT YOU STILL
HAVE TO MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT